hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play resolute dark
now this is a game that I found that I
have nothing no idea what it's about I
have no idea what I'm getting myself
into all I know is that it was highly
rated and it's a hoarding if you
couldn't pick up on that already so here
we go oh whoa hello what the hell oh
[ __ ] yeah I'm a little kid Oh what's is
our game like this for you play a little
kid that's coming out eventually Oh
where's where's my where's my dang oh
there it is I see it
who the hell are you don't know killing
you sense your fear oh how do I whoo
good that's all the flashlights I get
that's an oh I guess he they'll kill me
if they sense my fear I can't see
anything this flashlight is bull this is
it a flashlight this is nothing what did
I open what's going on where am i hey oh
god okay I'm trying to Navion what the
hell okay my file eyes just burst ended
lightness I look better I don't wanna
did I get the bout a battery I'm trying
to click on the batteries but I guess
this is some this is my damn that's
locked bruh bruh ha
Oh game this game it's Tara
I this games terrified I don't that ways
where's my parents room this is my
parents room two bathroom and bathtub
oh god oh god I've got the oh god I've
got the willies like you wouldn't
believe
Oh God okay my parents are not here I'm
assuming other dead oh well guess I'll
just have to be an orphan for those two
my life let's get out of the house ha ha
oh is that a vacuum cleaner
sounded like a vacuum after a bit huh
Iona oh no I don't know
oh god this is this is horrible
this game this game man oh it's an anime
ah little kid shouldn't be watching that
huh huh okie small gray key who's gonna
murder me by the way who who's who is
that that was gonna murder me I'm
outside oh this is probably not good
okay let's run away from home forever
good good I'm not supposed to swim in
the pool I was a little bitty pea okay I
heard a heartbeat out here I know you
guys can't see anything I can't either
so don't worry about it if it's dark
it's cuz it's dark he's a wood nothing
in here was this a shed you know it's
weirdest I'm I'm so creeped out by this
game and yet I haven't seen a single
monster what's that what is that what is
it what is that I hear water
yeah back in the house I don't wanna be
outside
oh okay yeah this um the best games
scare you without actually doing
anything to you they make you scare
yourself so I always said that the best
games make you I didn't quite catch that
sir need a place chair what about the
chair this
- please chair huh I'm pressing E is the
chair placed okay dog birds what and I
can't quite get up there can't quite see
what's in there I'm too short a little a
little kid I'm just a little kid all
right there buy something in there that
I need Oh God there's a key in the
kitchen okay so I'm assuming it's up in
the cabinet but I can't quite reach it
I'm too short my arms is too stubby I
see it no I see it that's the key isn't
it I just can't I can't jump all right
so see you to place chair I can't oh oh
okay I see the key give me the damn key
ah right screw the key I'm just going
elsewhere screw this and screw you and
screw this game dolls games good don't
screw skip the game is good I'm just a
pansy I'm just a big baby and I'm a
scaredy little little itty bitty baby
open oh not the basement not the
basement not not I'm not okay here we go
oh here we go what the hell hello with
it so at the door oh hi although we're
dating haha looks almost silly in
comparison to everything else in this
place did music just start up or am I
going crazy
Zen Zen me going crazy oh god it's the
back part of the basement I always hated
going here in the back part is not okay
I didn't quite catch that again but
whatever I was hated going in the back
basement I was a kid I used to be very
very very very afraid of the dark and
these how all these horror games that I
play aren't really helping me out
okay so ah now go back now go back to
the what - which room this room okay
who are you
I have a slash light what shadow my
shadow who I don't want to go anywhere
there's a to know what shadow huh those
you said don't see you soon hosannah go
back to the what and see the what go
back that I'm not staying in that room
second heads freakin shadows ooh oh the
kitchen I can now put the stool on
occasion No
okay so damn that's locked yo ah kitchen
kitchen here's the kitchen
no this is not the kitchen where the
frickin kitchen what the kitchen give me
the kitchen
give me the kitchen give me the kitchen
come on that's the back door where the
hell did the kitchen go wait what in
here now that's a bathroom again
oh this was the kitchen I'm an idiot
okay so see place the chair wait no
isn't this I I assumed that was gonna be
it cuz I see the key I got it didn't I
there's a place a chair I have the chair
right I have I have
don't chop me up please
I don't wanna be dead okay I have this
stool here this might this might just be
bugged actually I think cuz I'm pretty
sure this is what's supposed to happen
just eat a place to chair why am I
getting the press eat a place to chair
over here I'm pressing E but I I'm
thinking that something got bugged here
unfortunately which is really sad
because this game was going so well but
I don't know I may not be bugged I ha ha
ha ha I don't really know I don't really
know I don't really know and I uh I know
that key art I'm gonna go back in the
basement and shut up man I don't know
how to get rid of this painting I should
find something to get rid of that maybe
there was something else in the back
back area but I'd like ok nevermind
everyone baby there was something else
in the back area shirato
kill me shut up kill me shadows gonna
kill me I was gonna kill me Charlie's
gonna kill me shot I was going to kill
me Charlie's gonna kill me Charlie's
gonna show me shadows gotta go me
Charlie don't kill me shadow don't kill
me shadow
don't kill me shadow shadow don't kill
me ok all right so ok I think I get two
I think I get to get out of this game
early cuz I can't progress yay yay yay
this game God Anne okay so um if you
guys want to give this game a try and if
you guys figure out what's supposed to
happen here if this is bugged or if
something went wrong here
okay yeah I'm leaving alright so if you
guys want to try this game and you want
to give it you know a little playthrough
there is um the link in the description
below for you to download it it's really
well made I mean obviously the graphics
aren't superb but the atmosphere was
tremendous right from the get-go I was
terrified so I'm happy to get out of
here so thank you all someone for
watching let me know in the comments
what you think roof I did anything wrong
and I may revisit at some point down the
road so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
ah what